after our guests saw the life-changing
effects
of a good makeover they created a
non-profit
dedicated to helping women in need and
the organization is called
my fairy godfathers and founder stephen
anderson
and andrew ashton are here with us now
hi guys
[Applause]
nice to see you how are you oh my god
you guys
look like fairy godfathers like you just
have got that
like i see you and you've got that smile
and you look like you're awake and alive
and like
ready to fly in and change people's
lives i can see it all over you
so our that's it
i see the wings i do and it's nice
it's the glimmer in your eye and the
smiles on your faces
and steven as a hair stylist you say
that like
seeing the confidence in a woman after
she gets a haircut it inspired you
to do something even more beautiful can
you explain that
well yeah i mean we work on women every
single day we work on men and women but
women primarily
and um you know those few minutes that
were in the chair with that person
we need to make a change we make them
feel really good um
but uh we were approached to help a
young girl
uh go to the prom if we would donate
hair and makeup to her
and uh we did we said sure we would do
that but
we decided we would take it a little bit
further she said we asked her about her
dress she said she had
a dress and then we looked at it and we
said oh no
can't do that so we decided to create a
dress for her
and uh it just kind of blossomed from
there
and when we finished with the whole
transformation
she looked at herself and she's like wow
you guys are like my fairy godfathers
and
that's kind of how the name stuck well
and andrew
you've worked with some women who are
facing some serious
issues and i was wondering if you would
tell me about these women
oh wow um you know we've helped over 750
women so far since steven and i began
this journey
and um we've worked with women that have
been
through catastrophic illness or or
through financial hardship
um and a lot of times beyond their
control so we just felt like we needed
to go in and
let them feel their beauty again and
feel confident and empowered
and i think sometimes when you feel low
and you're you're going through
catastrophic illness and
and you've had to cut off all your hair
if you're going through chemo
uh you just want to feel like yourself
you want to feel beautiful again and
so that's why we created a you know give
wigs to women that are going through all
this and
we sit with them and we talk with them
and we style them out and and we go
through everything that we need to to
make them feel beautiful again
well we actually reached out to some of
these women
and yeah we have a little surprise for
you
check this out
[Music]
hi steven and andrew it's been so long
since i've been able to be blessed with
your presence
i definitely want to say thank you for
everything that you did for me
i left my senior prom feeling like
i was ready for the world when i met
them i was
lost i just didn't know there was more
to life like they helped me realize that
to have my fairy godfathers be able to
step in
in a moment where i needed them most was
so instrumental in my journey
and my confidence as a mom watching your
child
battle cancer was just just
the social part of it about feeling
beautiful and they just wanted to make
her feel
like a pretty princess i mean i
having my baby girl with me
seeing her face lit up because my face
lit up
and her you know
seeing my confidence that is what the
organization's about
it means more than just a wig they gave
me my power back
my fairy godfathers forever you are
life-changing
thank you for what you're doing
for women like myself thank you for
making me feel like myself again and
making me feel beautiful oh my god oh my
god that's great oh my god
you know it's i love to see people that
have been in the past i'm sorry
um no please feel it shows it shows that
we made a difference for them
in the short period of time that we were
with them and the experiences that we
can give to them hopefully they'll
remember for
their lifetime so sorry no i i mean what
what do you feel right now out of
curiosity
oh my heart is full it's just happiness
it's wonderful
that was a great surprise thank you
thank you so much it's
all both of you and you guys
are changing so many lives and as a
thank you by the way i started a beauty
company 10 years ago
flower beauty and we are going to send
you a
ton of stuff i'm talking about thousands
of dollars
hair tools and makeup so that
you have that at your disposal and we
also want to send you each
five thousand dollars totaling in ten
just you know a little something to
help aid and foster what you are
doing what you are already doing listen
this money doesn't compare this is our
way of saying thank you to you and
wanting to support and foster
what you are already doing oh thank you
thank you
so much i appreciate you having us thank
you thank you
go to our website to learn all about my
fairy godfathers